Welcome to English in a Minute, where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
Let's pretend you are in a major US city.
You are listening to an American English conversation and you hear this.
Hey, Bob.
Ever since you opened your coffee shop, you have been very busy.
Is the business going well and making money?
Yeah! I can't believe it.
It's going really well.
In fact, my coffee shop has become a real cash cow for me.
How does a cow produce cash?
Everyone knows cows make milk.
But in American English, a "cash cow" is a product or service...
...that makes a lot of money for a business.
This common phrase is used in casual and business conversations.
And when you use it, everyone will understand what you are saying.
And that's English in a Minute.